un bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour
cette fois aux questions stop séance qui
sera consacrée à une critique du
documentaire premier homme
documentaire français diffusée sur m6 en
2017 et donc pascal picq a été le
principal conseiller scientifique
pascal picq pour ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas est l'un des plus
célèbre paléoanthropologue français
c'est une critique que je n'avais pas
particulièrement envie de faire parce
que j'aime pas du tout critiquer les
efforts de vulgarisation scientifique
des autres surtout quand autant de
moyens ont été déployés pour les
réaliser mais vous avez été très
nombreux à me demander mon avis sur ce
documentaire donc je me suis payé la
curiosité de le regarder et pour vous
offrir mon avis très rapide sur ce que
j'ai pu voir
je ne le conseillerait absolument pas
pour une utilisation en salle de classe
quel que soit le niveau de la classe en
question c'est une histoire une
magnifique histoire mais 90% de ce qu'on
y voit c'est de la fiction
donc si ceux ci ce documentaire avait
été un film si ça avait été la guerre du
feu si ça avait été grevé robin des bois
si ça avait été un apporte quoi d'autre
jurassic park
je n'aurais eu absolument aucun problème
avec ce documentaire le fait est qu'il a
été de vendu comme un documentaire et
par conséquent s'attend à trouver de
l'information
on s'attend à trouver de l'information à
l'intérieur et en l'occurrence il ya
très très peu de choses qui sont
factuels dans dans ce documentaire
donc non c c'est un beau film mais ce
n'est pas un documentaire tels que
j'aimerais en voir et elle que je
l'utiliserai moi même à des fins
d'éducation
j'aime l'initiative j'aime beaucoup
l'initiative qui est un documentaire
soit français et spas américains ça
c'est une très très bonne c'est une très
très bonne chose
il a plusieurs bons points plusieurs
très bons points notamment il prend en
compte les nouveautés les choses
nouvelles notamment au monal est dit
australopithecus sediba donc c'est un
documentaire qui où les gens ont essayé
d'être à jour où les gens qui l'ont fait
se sont maintenues à jour mais sur le
fond je ne suis qu'à 1 % de satisfaction
réellement 1 % de satisfaction 19% de
ouais pourquoi pas et le 80 % qui reste
c'est du what the fuck
c'est le 80 % qui restent n'ont rien à
faire dans un documentaire dans un film
oui pas de problème mais dans un
documentaire
non alors quel est mon principal
problème avec ce documentaire et c'est
là je pense que que cette critique que
cette vidéo peut s'avérer utile c'est
que ce documentaire comme est vraiment
l'erreur classique qu'on voit dans la
plupart des documentaires c'est que à
des fins de et là j'ouvre des grosses
guillemets simplification et ben on
recommence on commence l'histoire et en
fait ça ne simplifie absolument rien de
romance et l'histoire au contraire ça
rajoute des choses à une histoire qui
existe déjà
l'histoire telle qu'elle est telle qu'on
la lit dans le registre fossile et à
cette histoire on superpose une autre
histoire romancée pour la rendre soit
disant plus intéressantes et pour
simplifier le côté scientifique et moi
j'aime pas ça du tout ou du moins
j'aimerais ça si et seulement si à un
moment dans le documentaire on nous
disait voilà le fossile et voilà
l'histoire qu'on en tire et voilà ce qui
est inventé et voilà ce qui ne l'est pas
voilà donc ce documentaire comme
beaucoup d'autres est par exemple et là
je vais citer vraiment les exemples
l'exemple plus classique c'est sur la
terre des dinosaures sur la terre des
dinosaures est un magnet est une
magnifique série de documentaires mais
dans l'absolu ya rien c'est le même
contenu c'est 90% d'invention 10% de
science c'est pareil on fait plein de
belles histoires mais il n'y a pas un
seul faux cils à la clé quoi on fait des
milliers d' hypothèses qui peuvent être
ou sérieuses ou délirantes afin de
raconter une jolie histoire mais jamais
on ne vous montre les preuves
c'est à dire que
du coup on arrive à un moment où
justement il ya des hypothèses qui sont
sérieuses et y en a d'autres qui sont
délirantes et comme on n'a jamais la
preuve que ces hypothèses sont soutenus
ou pas come on come on ne sait pas
jusqu'à quel point ces hypothèses sont
soutenus et bien au final on ne sait pas
démêler le vrai de la fiction et moi
c'est le gros problème que j'ai eu avec
ce documentaire que j'ai eu avec le
reportage sur la terre des dinosaures
c'est le problème que j'ai avec la
plupart des documentaires en général
c'est qu'on ne nous montre pas les
fossiles et là je vais prendre un
exemple tout simple
toumaï on passe presque 20 minutes voire
même 30 minutes à parler donc de toumaï
c'est-à-dire sahel entre opus on parle
de son organisation sociale on parle de
l'utile de l'utilisation des outils on
parle de la domination des mâles on
parle de la rivalité entre groupes on
parle des relations amoureuses on parle
même du rapport à la mort mais à aucun
moment on nous on ne nous rappelle que
toumaï c'est juste un seul crâne et
c'est tout faya un crâne et un petit peu
de matériel à côté mais toumaï
fondamentalement on a on a juste le seul
truc qui est bien préservée c'est un
crâne je crois il doit y avoir un
morceau de mandibules il ya un petit
bout de femme mûre qui est très très
débattue et c'est tout ce qu'on a c'est
tout ce qu'on a tous my ya qu une seule
occurrence dans le registre fossile
comparé à néanderthal et à tout ce qu'on
pourrait dire des fossiles de néandertal
toumaï on n'a rien tout ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'ils marchaient debout qu'il
vivait en forêt et que c'était un très
proche parent des hominidés des
homininés qui sont venus après donc les
australopithèques les hardes hippie tech
et c'est tout mais c'est tout donc voila
moi j'aurais aimé cette histoire de à
propos de sa haine entre opus si au bout
d'un moment on nous avait dit ah au fait
le fossile c'est ça et voilà et c'est
tout donc là tout ce que vous allez
entendre tout ce que vous avez entendu
pardon c'était globalement roman c'est
quoi mais non ça on ne le dit pas pareil
le le reportage passe énormément de
temps à nous expliquer l'évolution des
rapports de dominance entre hommes
femmes à être entre mâles et femelles à
travers les millions d'années ces
casiers cerner un point où c'est
quasiment centrale dans
dans la thématique du reportage mais je
vois pas où sont les fossiles quoi c'est
pareil c'est de l'invention pure et dure
ça je veux dire ça fait peut-être très
plaisir aux gens qui s'intéressent à
l'étude de l'évolution des rapports de
dominance entre hommes et femmes mais au
final je ne sais pas où sont les données
qu'ils soutiennent que au départ
c'étaient les hommes qui dominent et
puis ça a été les femmes puis sert les
hommes et ainsi de suite quoi bein non
non non si on regarde juste les données
actuelles globalement les chimpanzés
vous avez les bonobos d'un côté ou c'est
les femelles qui domine et vous avez les
chimpanzés commun chez qui c'est les
mâles qui domine et en dehors de ça je
vois pas ce que vous voulez dire de plus
quoi je ne vois pas quel inférences vous
pouvez en tirer sur l'origine de
l'évolution des rapports dominants ce
mâle femelle chez l'homme
voilà donc c'est exactement ça c'est où
s'arrête le fantasme et où commence le
l'information et dans un documentaire je
trouve que c'est grave dans un film
encore une fois j'aurais pas de problème
mais dans un documentaire je trouve que
c'est extrêmement grave et c'est comme
je le disais donc c'est un problème
qu'on retrouve dans tous les
documentaires alors quand on vous parle
d extinction de masse quand on vous
montre des dinosaures si jai 3d machin
super reconstruction on vous dit pas où
ça s'arrête
où s'arrête la romance et où commence la
formation vous dit pas comment démêler
le vrai du faux
donc voila moi je suis très sceptique
quant à ses reportages y en a qui sont
très bon âge et j'ai récemment vu à
thann boro et le géant où là on vous
montre le fossile
on vous montre ce qu'on regarde et après
on vous le reconstruire en site j aie
pour vous dire voilà ce que quel organe
c'était comment ça fonctionnait donc ça
c'est un très très beau reportage at
attenborough et et le géant mais non là
pour premier rhum je suis désolé c'est
c'est un point négatif c'est clairement
sanctions voilà maintenant mon avis un
peu plus dans le détail mais là je vais
je vais quand même essayer de pas trop
m'étaler ce qu'il ya c'est quand même un
reportage de 1h30 donc je vais je vais
quand même essayer d'être bref
donc commençons par le début pierrot la
pit et cus à pied ap les pierrots la
dent
documentaire alors il est vendu comme
l'ancêtre des grands singes alors déjà
là déjà là c'est super mal expliqué
qu'il est l'ancêtre des grands singes de
la façon où ils le disent en fait on
dirait que c'est l'ancêtre de l'homme
alors qu'en fait l'orang outan est plus
proche de l'homme que ne l'est pierrot
l'appli pierrot la pythie cus on
comprend pas trop bien où ils veulent en
venir quant aux relations de parenté de
pierrot l'api tqs avec nous et voilà il
suffisait de dire c'est même si j'aime
pas l'emploi du mot ancêtres dans ce
contexte là mais voilà c'est l'ancêtre
des grands singes quoi dit que c'est
l'ancêtre des grands sages d'ipoque
c'est l'ancêtre de l'homme quoi ça ça
fait un peu mal à entendre c'est surtout
ça jettent de la confusion parce qu'au
final on sait plus qui on parle qui est
l'ancêtre de l'homme du coup dont il
cette histoire sachant qu'ils sont tous
d'ancêtre de l'homme il ya il ya eu ce
petit point qui m'a qui m'a un peu
titillé sur pierrot la pythie cus le
reste bon bah comme j'ai dit c'est
romancé c'est une belle histoire et
après il ya tous à la fin de cette
section sur pierrot la pit et qu on a un
scénario de migration depuis l'europe
vers l'afrique donc des grands singes
qui ont émigré depuis l'europe vers
l'afrique et qui implique que les grands
singes d'europe seraient les ancêtres
des grands sages d'afrique et donc des
humains et donc que les humains ultime
manche finalement aurait une origine
européenne
ça fait mal à voir ça quand même ça ça
m'a fait un peu mal à voir c'est pas
pour autant qu'on sache et pour autant
que je sache c'est faux c'est faux parce
que déjà ils disent que ils disent que
pierrot la pythie cus a traversé la
méditerranée à pied c'est qu'il ya 7
millions d'années pas il a traversé la
méditerranée à pied sec ou pour donner
naissance à sahel entre opus donc ça
elle entre aux puces il a sept millions
d'années 6 7 millions d'années ça veut
dire que pierrot l'api tqs a traversé la
méditerranée avant or la crise
messinienne c'est à dire la crise de
salinité le la crise de salinité
géologique qui nous permet de savoir
qu'à l'époque la méditerranée étaient à
sec elle n'a pas 7 millions d'années
elle a que 5 millions d'années donc elle
est plus jeune que sahelanthropus donc
en gros il est impossible que pierrot
l'api tqc traverser la méditerranée à
pied sec pour donner naissance à ça il
entre aux puces c'est pas possible ou
même qu'une espèce
directement européenne ait pu faire ça
n'importe quelle espèce
donc en réalité non pierre laffitte et
qu ce n'est pas l'ancêtre de l'homme de
toute façon il est lens à la limite
c'est le plus proche parent de l'ancêtre
commun des grands singes l'orang outan
lui est plus proche de l'homme et
laurent autant lui il est en asie et le
gibbon il est aussi en asie donc les
deux grands singes les plus basses eaux
sont en réalité en asie de grandes
chances en que l'ancêtre commun des
grands singes soigner en asie et
qu'après l'ancêtre commun du gorille de
l'homme et du chimpanzé soit né en
afrique
donc on est plus sur une image europe
d'abord puis asie puis afrique et donc
quelque chose qui aurait finalement fait
le tour de la méditerranée et que
scénario qui est beaucoup plus logique
avec ce qu'on sait de la crise
messinienne puisque je le répète la
crise messinienne ne date pas d'avant
sahelanthropus elle ne date pas d'avant
toumaï et ensuite on passe à toumaï donc
salée sahelanthropus sahelanthropus qui
nous est vendu comme étant l'ancêtre
commun des chimpanzés et des hommes
et ça ça c'est complètement nouveau je
n'étais pas au courant
1 c c'est pas que ce soit archi faux
mais pour dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont à l'heure actuelle aucune
analyse sérieuse n'a jamais placé toumaï
ailleurs qu'à l'intérieur de la lignée
humaine c'est à dire que jamais aucune
analyse phylogénétique n'a placé toumaï
ailleurs que plus proche de l'homme
qu'il ne l'ait du chimpanzé
c'est à dire que pour que toumaï soit
l'ancêtre commun des chimpanzés et des
hommes il faut qu'il faut qu'il ait le
même apparentements et à l'un et à
l'autre il faut pas qu'ils soient plus
proches de l'un ou de l'autre
et en l'occurrence jamais aucune analyse
phylogénétique n'a suggéré que toumaï
était aussi proche du chimpanzé qui ne
l'est de l'homme
il a toujours été retrouvés du côté des
hommes très très bas très bas dans la
phylogénie le plus banal possible dans
la phylogénie mais jamais du côté
chimpanzé ou jamais de façon irrésolu
c'est à dire que à l'intérieur de la
lignée humaine
il est ce qu'il y a de plus proche de
l'ancêtre commun du chimpanzé et des
hommes mais dire qu'il est l'ancêtre
commun du chapeau
des hommes c'est faux il est plus proche
de l'homme donc ça déjà ça ça m'a un
petit peu ça m'a un petit peu surpris
d'entendre ça à côté de ça on nous vend
l'idée que la bipédie était du coup un
caractère de sahel entre opus ce qui est
vrai donc pour ça je suis je suis tout à
fait d'accord la bipédie était
effectivement l'une des caractéristiques
de sahel entre eux puces pour autant
qu'on sache c'est à dire que la seule
chose qu'on est je le rappelle de style
entre opus c'est un crâne et des petits
rogatons à droite et à gauche mais pour
autant qu'on ait pu étudier le crâne la
position du du trou d'entrée de la
moelle épinière dans le dans le crâne
est situé de telle façon que la colonne
vertébrale ne pouvait être que verticale
sous le crâne et pas horizontale
derrière le crâne
donc a priori on est d'accord que toumaï
devait être bipèdes du moine ya un
consensus là dessus le problème c'est
que comme on nous dit que toumaï est
l'ancêtre commun des chimpanzés des
hommes ça en vient à dire que l'ancêtre
des chimpanzés était bipède et ça cette
idée de bipédie de l'an de l'ancêtre des
chimpanzés
je sais pas qu'il la sortie la première
fois mais c'est une idée qu'on retrouve
très souvent et honnêtement je ne sais
absolument pas d'où ça sort donc si vous
le savez s'il vous plaît envoyez moi les
liens vers les articles scientifiques
dans les commentaires parce que je suis
très curieux de savoir qui le premier a
suggéré que les chimpanzés était bipède
à la base et sur quel matériel à partir
de quelles données il a fait ça est ce
que c'était sur les données des
chimpanzés actuelle est ce que c'était à
partir des fossiles ce dont je doute
fortement puisqu'il n'y a pas ou très
peu de fossiles de chimpanzés en réalité
donc voilà aussi loin qu'on sache et
aussi loin qu'on connaisse le registre
fossile la bipédie c'est un caractère
d'homininés et pas de panini pas de
chimpanzés du coup donc ça c'est curieux
c'est une idée que voilà si vous savez
d'où elle sort je suis preneur mais en
tout cas en ce qui me concerne c'est pas
quelque chose que je valide dans l'état
actuel de mes connaissances
on nous parle ensuite des rites
funéraires chetumal rites funéraires
donc pour lequel je le rappelle on a
absolument aucune preuve
il n'y a pas de fausse il n'y a rien qui
documentent si oui ou non il y avait des
rites funéraires donc je peux pas dire
que c'est pas le cas si ça se trouve
c'était le cas mais par contre là où ça
commence à devenir un peu bizarre c'est
que juste après tout toumaï on nous
parle de mona les 10es au monal et 10
pour le coup il a été fortement suggéré
qu'il y avait rites funéraires
donc pourquoi parler de rites funéraires
chez toumaï alors que juste après il
parle d'une autre espèce qui est homo
naledi et qui l avait des rites
funéraires et là pour le coup il n'en
parle pas la jeu il ya un truc qui
m'échappe complètement pour au monal est
dit dans le cas de mona lee dit c'est
quand même la meilleure hypothèse qu'on
est pour expliquer pourquoi il ya autant
de squelettes juste d'aumône à lady au
même endroit voilà il n'existe aucun
phénomène naturel non induit par l'homme
qui sélectionne uniquement des squelette
d'hominidé pour les planqués dans un
coin ça n'existe pas il n'ya que l'homme
qui planquent c'est fou ce que l'est
tous au même endroit on appelle ça des
cimetières donc et c'est pour ça que je
trouve extrêmement curieux de
transitionner de toumaï à au monal et 10
mai pour autant d'attributs et le rite
funéraire à toumaï parce que pour tout
maïs est purement et simplement de la
fiction ou en l'occurrence de la
spéculation sur base non rationnel
puisque sur base de rien du tout alors
que dans le cas d' homo naledi au moins
ça aurait été de la spéculation
rationnelle sera étaient de la
spéculation sur base de quelque chose
sur base de preuves
donc c'est bizarre ça nous emmène à homo
naledi donc qui nous est vendu comme un
on ne sait pas si ces homos ou
australopithecus donc je cite au monal
ai dit nous est vendu comme de poing
ouvrez les guillemets on ne sait pas si
ces homos ou australopithèques us alors
qu'encore une fois il ya aucune analyse
qui suggère que c'était
australopithèques us ya aucune analyse
phylogénétique qui a suggéré que homo
naledi était autre chose que homo donc
voilà que les choses soient dites et
éclair au monal et 10 jusqu'à preuve du
contraire c'est au mot et ça j'ai plus
l'impression que c'est quand même une
particularité française particularité
qui vient du fait que homo naledi à un
petit cerveau donc ces australopithèques
us mais je le rappelle on ne classe pas
avec des caractères primitif et la
petite taille du cerveau est un
caractère primitif mais en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que les analyse
phylogénétique qui avait été pratiqué en
avait à 100% démontré que mona les dix
était homo naledi c'était au mot voilà
mais par contre ce qu'on nous dit à la
fin de mona lady et qu'il a vraiment ma
m'a choqué on nous dit que aumône à
l'e10 est scindée en deux groupes
des gens qui sont allés dans la savane
et qui sont devenus homo erectus
admettons et des gens qui sont partis
dans les arbres et qui sont devenus
n'est pas rentrer opus alors pas rentrer
opus c'est c'est ce qu'on appelait les
australopithèques robustes c'est à dire
qu'on sait très bien que les parents
trotte descendent d'un truc qu'on
appelle un australopithèque et non pas
d'un homo et les parents trop puces
c'est des australopithèques ultra
spécialisé dans la la mastication de
nourriture végétale donc cédé des hommes
super végétarien voilà cd cd v gagnent
plus plus ils ont des mâchoires
gigantesque qu'ils ont des dents
absolument énorme des muscles mastic
ateurs puissant et encore une fois il ya
aucun doute que parent trope les parents
trope descendent de ce qu'on appelle les
australopithèques alors mais voilà il
n'y a pas de doute sur le fait que homo
et part entre opus ce sont deux genres
distincts qui n'ont rien à voir
et là on nous dit au monal est dit est
l'ancêtre des parents trope et d'homo
erectus
waouh dans las et j'ai du mal à croire
que pascal picq et valider ça je sais
pas s'il l'a vu ça c'est pas possible je
dirais tu sais où c'est dur c'est très
dur à entendre
bref on reconnaîtra néanmoins à la fin
du passage sur aumône à lady une volonté
de coller à l'actualité
donc déjà en parlant de mona lady et en
parlant aussi d'australopithecus sediba
en parlant de plusieurs choses qui sont
nouvelles
au moment et le retrace l'origine du
genre homo ce qui nous emmène du coup à
homo erectus alors homo erectus dans ce
dans ce reportage est représenté de
façon extrêmement humaine c'est à dire
que homo erectus est basiquement dans le
film
un être humain moderne avec les dents
qui partent vers la banque ou en gros
c'est à peu près juste ça qui les
différencie des hommes modernes et du
coup il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
venus me voir pour me demander est-ce
que c'est du sérieux tout ça est ce que
homo erectus ressembler à ce point un
homme moderne
j'ai envie de dire que oui du moins
spontanément j'avais envie de dire que
oui mais c'était avant de voir
effectivement ce que ce que les gens
appelaient ressembler à un humain
moderne ce que j'avais pas encore vu le
documentaire à ce moment là donc
maintenant que j'ai vu le documentaire
il ya quand même des choses que ces homo
erectus on est que et qu'il ne devrait
pas avoir en l'occurrence ils ont un
menton donc sur la mâchoire inférieure
il ya un petit menton qui part vers
l'avant ça c'est un truc d'humains 100%
moderne
aucun hominidés ni aucun primates avant
homo sapiens n'avait de menton même
l'homme de néandertal donc le menton
c'est un truc qu'on ne retrouve que chez
l'homme moderne donc en l'occurrence il
aurait fallu faire un peu de maquillage
et peut-être quelques prothèse pour
cacher ce menton chez les acteurs qui
ont joué qui ont joué les homo erectus
parce que le menton c'est quelque chose
qui ne devrait pas avoir et par contre
il ya un truc qu'il devrait avoir
et c'est à bourg les supras orbitaire
c'est à dire une espèce de grosse barre
au dessus des yeux là une sorte de
casquettes qui était extrêmement
prononcée chez homo erectus
donc ça ça c'est quelque chose qui il
devrait avoir et qu'ils n'ont pas et ça
ça veut devrait leur donner une allure
qui voit là un peu comme on représente
habituellement les les hommes de
néandertal quoi maintenant il ya un
autre truc c'est la pilosité
en gros ils ont une pilosité d'homme
moderne à savoir pote poils du tout bon
ben là là pour le cool je rejoins ceux
qui ont fait ce documentaire donc pour
autant qu'on sache la pilosité c'est
quelque chose qui aurait disparu il ya
1,2 million d'années donc pourquoi est
ce qu'on pense ça c'est parce qu'il ya
un gène qui code pour l'expression de la
mélanine et que ce gène aurait bu subi
une mutation significative il y a un
vieux 1,2 million d'années tels que daté
par l'horloge moléculaire et que cette
mutation aurait rendu la peau des êtres
humains
noir il y à 1,2 million d'années or
avoir la peau noire ça n'a d'intérêt que
si elle est nue ce que si vous n'avez
pas la peau nue c'est vos poils qui
protège votre peau des radiations du
soleil et pas la mélanine que vous avez
directement dans la peau donc les
chimpanzés par exemple ils ont la peau
blanche parce que c'est l'heure c'est
leurs poils qui protègent leur peau mais
apparemment il ya un avis il ya 1,2
million d'années la peau des gens est
devenu foncé et cela veut dire qu'il y
avait plus de poils
or il ya 1,2 million d'années qu'elle
était l'espèce que l'on rencontrait sur
terre c'était homo erectus
il y en avait d'autres il ya toujours eu
plusieurs espèces dans les parages
quelle que soit l'époque à laquelle on
se trouve il ya toujours eu plusieurs
espèces d'hominidés mais il ya deux
millions d'années l'espèce la plus
proéminente j'ai envie de dire ces homo
erectus
donc j'ai pas de problème particulier
avec le fait qu'on dise que voilà le ils
avaient ils n'étaient pas poilu après
laon on peut commencer à chipoter c'est
qu'ils se gênent ne peut se trouver que
chez les espèces qui sont directement
ancestrale à l'homme moderne est pas la
branche morte cas était homo erectus en
asie hélas ce qu'on nous montre dans ce
reportage ces homo erectus d'asie
spécifiquement donc web on peut il ya
moyen de chipoter quoi il ya moyen de
chipoter mais là en l'occurrence jeu
non je valide plutôt leur choix j'aurais
plutôt tendance à valider leur choix et
il est il est bon à mon avis de se
représenter homo erectus d'une façon un
peu moins sauvage et bourrin que qu'on
se le représente habituellement quoi un
peu moins sauvage et un peu plus un être
humain
on sait comment erectus avait fort peu
de différence avec les êtres humains
modernes à part justement le menton le
bourrelet sus orbitaire et la capacité
crânienne qui était légèrement plus
réduite mais dans le cas d' homo erectus
d'asie pas de beaucoup
homo erectus d'asie on est sur 1200
centimètres cubes de moyenne homo
sapiens moderne ses 1400 centimètres
cubes de moyenne donc il n'y a pas de
voilà donc globalement aspect humain je
dis ok pourquoi pas mais il ya quand
même cette histoire de menton et de
bourg les suces orbitaire que j'aurais
bien aimé que j'aurais bien aimé voir
par contre pour ce qui est de la couleur
de la peau là où ça m'ennuie un peu
c'est quand on retourne en afrique pour
l'origine d'homo sapiens alors le le
documentaire ce le documentaire se clôt
là-dessus il n'y a pas de spoiler alert
on sait tous comment ça se termine homo
sapiens apparaît et homo sapiens
conquiert le monde et provoque
l'extinction de tous ses cousins
d'ailleurs au passage sais c'est pas une
histoire qui est particulièrement
joyeuse de base
mais voilà homo sapiens apparaît
provoque l'extinction de tous ses
compatriotes
le truc c'est que dans ces homo sapiens
d'afrique
il y a une petite demoiselle à la peau
claire et ça justement comme j'aime le
dire c'est qu'il n'y a pas de raison que
quelqu'un ait eu la peau claire
à une époque où homo sapiens et venait
d'apparaître en afrique et de tout ceci
étant dû au fait que l'homme a grandi en
afrique et donc à une peau qui est
adapté au niveau d'insolation qui est
celui de l'afrique
est il besoin de protection donc on va
pas il n'y a pas de considérations
raciales derrière ça c'est purement et
simplement de la biologie en afrique
avoir la peau claire c'est pas un
avantage c'est pas un cadeau à l'époque
où il n'y avait pas la crème solaire du
moins
vous faisiez pas long feu avec la peau
claire donc ya pas de raison que qui que
ce soit ait eu la peau claire
à l'époque j'aime j'aime la
représentation de la diversité
j'aime la diversité humaine met pas un
point où ça en vient à dire des choses
fausses non plus quoi voilà c'est un peu
c'est un peu mon problème est encore une
fois ça ne m'aurait pas embêté dans une
fiction mais dans un documentaire
ouais non non ça passe moyens ça passe
moyens donc voilà c'est tout ce que
j'avais à dire à propos de ce reportage
donc les premiers roms c'est c'est le
genre de reportage qui me font me
questionner sur sur la qualité de ce que
je peux voir quand il s'agit de sujets
que je connais pas quand vous regardez
un reportage sur les galaxies sur
l'espace le cosmos donc s'il ya autant
de vérité dans ces reportages que je
vois sur l'origine de l'univers que dans
les reportages que je vois sur l'origine
de l'homme ou des reportages comme ça
sur l'origine de l'homme eh bien eh ben
je m'étonne pas que les qui autant de
créationnistes vraiment jeu c'est normal
que les gens gobent pâle ce qu'on leur
dise pas ce que parce que c'est pas vrai
ce qu'on leur dit je viens on leur dit
on leur dit voilà un reportage ça va
vous apprendre des choses est en réalité
aucune des informations qu'on leur donne
n'est vérifiable
parce que c'est de la fiction c'est
juste de la fiction ce qu'on leur montre
on peut pas montrer aux gens 1% devrait
dans 99 fondu dans 99 % de fiction et
espérer après ça que les gens vous
regardent en disant mais vous savez quoi
les scientifiques ont raison non il est
important quand on raconte quelque chose
quand on quand on raconte une histoire
de séparer le vrai du faux de montrer ce
qui est basé sur des preuves et ce qui
est fictionnelle je ne demande pas à ce
que des efforts comme ça ne se
reproduise pas au contraire je
l'encouragent il est bon de faire des
documentaires
il est bon d'éduquer les gens mais on
n'éduque pas les gens on ne leur
montrant rien et c'est ça mon problème
on n'éduque pas les gens en leur
montrant rien il faut montrer sur koi no
inférences sont basés il faut montrer
sur quoi notre réflexion se construit
voici le crâne de ça l entreprise voici
ce qu'on peut en dire
et voici
l'histoire qu'on va vous raconter à à
partir de ça voilà mais à partir de là
on dit que c'est une histoire voilà
c'est juste une histoire c'est tout et
moi j'aurais été 200% content quoi
j'aurais été 200% pour mais là je peux
pas je peux pas décemment conseiller à
des instituteurs à des profs à des des
maîtres de conférences d'utiliser ce
genre de matériel pour être pour
l'éducation ni même à des journalistes
de l'utiliser pour pour écrire des
articles c'est non c'est pas c'est un
bon matériel mais qui n'est pas présenté
de la bonne façon
voilà ce je pense que ça conclut bien
cette vidéo
donc si vous avez aimé me voir souffrir
m'entendre souffrir durant cette vidéo
et si vous aimez les critiques de l'aube
du mans terre et que vous voulez que je
refasse des critiques constructives
évidemment pas d pad et démolissage pas
des clashs pas des déblocages des choses
constructives qui permettent de pointer
du doigt des erreurs qui sont souvent
faites dans les documentaires et qui ne
devrait pas les clés et sur lequel il
faut être vigilant parce que c'est des
cds points qui reviennent très souvent
dans les documentaires et dames
n'hésitez pas faites en sorte que cette
vidéo fasse début partager
mettez du pouce bleus gens demandent
jamais mais là pour le coup c'est le
seul moyen que vous avez de me faire
savoir que vous aimez ce que je fais ou
pas donc si vous ça vous a plu
montrez le genre ferait si ça ne vous a
pas plu montrer le et je le referais pas
pas de souci et en attendant et bien je
vous dis à très bientôt sur stop science